so the class was started in 2011 that
was the first time it was offered in the
fall semester of 2011 it was founded by
professor Seth teller who has done a lot
of work over the past couple of decades
particularly in computer vision and in
robotics and I think over time I think
he saw that a lot of the work that he
was doing could also be applicable to
assistive technology or technologies
that can help people with disabilities
live more independently or help them in
their day-to-day lives so I think over
the over the past maybe decade or so
he's been involved in a lot of course
creation creating robotics courses and
other undergraduate courses in
electrical engineering computer science
and I think that this class was in a lot
of ways kind of an extension to that to
some extent focused on assistive
technology over the years I think Seth
had a chance to work in assistive
technology in research projects and then
interact a lot with people with
disabilities in the cambridge area or
the boston area and really get a sense
of the kinds of practical challenges the
theme that they face and how technology
could help so that really i think was
the motivation for starting the class
trying to work with this group of people
and also to tap into the interest of
undergraduate students to work on
service learning projects or to apply
their design and engineering skills to
something something meaningful so so he
taught this class for the past three
years and we were fortunate to be
teaching at this this fall
in terms of departmental support for the
class so because professor teller was
part of the electrical engineering and
computer science department MIT that's
mainly where it has been house for the
last three and this year as well so for
years I'm going forward we're actually
looking to cross lista class between
electrical engineering computer science
mechanical engineering as well as health
sciences and technology and so I would
say that when it was housed within
electrical engineering and computer
science we had a lot of computer science
students come to us and so a lot of the
projects ended up being you know
software related projects because that
was scoffs and that's what they were
comfortable with and but we've also seen
a lot of assistive technology requires
hardware design as well and so that's
why we're bringing in mechanical
engineering support for the class and as
for health sciences and Technology their
role at MIT is really to serve as this
integrative force between different
facets of engineering and the medical
community and so what we're hoping to do
next year with HSTs health science and
technology support is to bring in
occupational therapists into the class
as well to help the students with their
projects so yeah just in thinking about
the different skill sets they go into
the projects we do things software
hardware and then being able to
interface with the health side of things
it's very important